and then this guy uh uh Elon I believe
his name is oh that's you're having here
yesterday he's coming on after this oh
okay oh no good blasphemy looks like a
homosexual to me oh no and what is that
God awful shirt he's wearing I like it I
think he looks good he looks like
Pugsley from Adam's family no okay
yeah I think he looks awesome I think he
looks disgusted so I want to thank you
Terry Joe for being here can we pound it
or is that no good hey on me you want to
pay on me because no pound it oh as a
Orthodox Jew we also want to convert
okay so pound it for the game what a
repelling I just want to congratulate
you on your work and keep it up yeah
this okay yeah just keep it converting
okay yeah I'll definitely be doing that
thank you all right so that's Terry Joe
we have ALS access point
all right bye Terry thanks for coming